pour accompagner les entreprises à ce
moment là parce qu'il avait vraiment
comme vous disiez au début de votre
interview le moral des troupes était
vraiment à 0 des entreprises fermées
vous imaginez 0 chiffre d'affaires pour
des charges à couvrir
donc nous n'avons pas attendu
effectivement et nous sommes mais
toujours mais plus près des entreprises
de manière concrète des entreprises qui
notamment ont par exemple de grosses
difficultés de trésorerie parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya et notamment les les
petites ou très petites entreprises
c'est bien ça le problème les grosses
qui ont qui ont de la réserve en quelque
sorte ou qui ont le soutien de leurs
banques bons peuvent voir venir
peut-être encore pendant quelques mois
mais celle qui va vraiment de 13
entreprises à monter ces prêts à avoir
ces aides à obtenir ces aides d'ailleurs
un déblocage des aides qui rentrait de
se faire ça prend peut-être un peu de
temps parce que c'est vrai que au niveau
de l'administration souhaite toujours un
peu compliqué mais on a été vraiment
plus près moi je vous parlais du secteur
du tourisme
si vous voulez le président philippe joc
a eu plusieurs webinaire avec la mise d
outre-mer et le secrétaire d'état au
tourisme est le maître mot c'est et de
ne laisser personne sur le carreau
donc nous avons ce qu'on appelle à la
chambre un dispositif qui s'appelle là
vous pourriez vous pouvez assurer que
c'est le cas à placer bien sûr la
qualité tourisme 40 et tous risques est
un dispositif de l'état représente ici
par la dieccte et qualité tourisme nous
avons à peu près 120 entreprises du
secteur du tourisme ce n'est pas
beaucoup nous espérons avoir plus et
nous avons réussi grâce à nous
conseiller à retrouver six ans des
entreprises à leur proposer tous les
dispositifs qui étaient disponibles pour
elle vraiment sonné vous seules caisses
de l'état que ces deux là c'était ben
voilà c'est ce que j'allais vous dirai
ce que vous faites justement le lien
vous êtes vous êtes l'interface nous
entre ces entreprises en grande
difficulté et donc ces organismes
notamment l'état la ctn acquis qui ont
mis des dispositifs en place quelques
mots du plan de relance mais qui a été
annoncé présentez là il ya quelques
jours par le gouvernement par la voix du
premier ministre
on sait qu'il ya un volet
outre-mer alors un volet outre-mer qui
est pas vraiment dans tout connaît pas
on ne connaît pas exactement là et ici
on est un tour voilà on a annoncé un
chiffre donc plan de relance on le
rappelle sur le plan de relance
un milliard et demi sont alloués à
l'outre-mer mans sans répartition
précise encore mais on a quelques axes
prioritaires qui ont été quand même
présenté par le gouvernement ça ça vous
va notamment bon d'abord des mesures
sociales pour la formation
l'augmentation des deux contrats aidés
on revient aux contrats aidés un peu et
puis 50 millions alloués à la rénovation
des réseaux d'eau
alors pour tout l'outre-mer à ce pas 50
millions pour la martinique bon voilà et
puis etc etc
on y reviendra parce qu'il ya aussi le
btp vous l'avez évoqué alors écoutez on
va attendre effectivement d'avoir ses
contours je sais que j'ai une réunion ce
matin en préfecture avec les politiques
et les socio économiques autour du
préfet donc j'espère qu'on en saura plus
maintenant je crois qu'il faut pas
attendre je pas justement qu'il faut que
nous soyons force de proposition et que
nous fassions des propositions ce que
nous avons commencé à faire à la chambre
de commerce estimant le président choqué
le bureau nous avons mis en place des
rencontres tout au long du confinement
ne sommes pas restés là attentiste nous
avons effectivement prévu déjà essayer
de voir comment on pouvait sortir les
entreprises du marin c'est vraiment ça
donc on a fait des propositions ce sont
des propositions qu'on a soumise à la
ctm je sais qu'il y en a certaines qui
ont été retenus effectivement et vous
faut il faire ses propositions finales
et qu'il faut pas attendre il faut pas
attendre mais est ce que vous voulez que
vos propositions et vos fléchage en
quelque sorte soient réellement prises
en compte
c'est important que ce soit fait de
toutes les façons pas ce que ce soit
fait il faut que ce soit fait je sais
qu'il ya à peu près une centaine de
dossiers dont 40% concernent le
développement durable donc ça c'est déjà
on est complètement dans les clous si on
regarde le verdissement dont parle le
premier ministre le milliard et demi
annoncé c'est un peu leur enveloppe
globale attribuée non mais on nous dit
alors c'est là qu'il faudra peut-être
aussi déterminer les choses avec le
représentant de l'état
là vous dites qu'il ya une réunion ce
jour 1 ce mercredi le gouvernement a
l'air de dire que ce milliard et demi
c'est ce qui a alloué au ministère de
l'outre-mer
mais que les territoires pourront
également y marges et à l'ensemble des
mesures nationales du plan de relance
tout à fait en fonction de chaque monde
et ya des dom à l'ancien plan de relance
du du mirail faudra être très attentif
très attentif là j'ai des gens vraiment
toutes les start up être très attentif 7
milliards d'euros pour le numérique et
pour les start up
c'est une annonce de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance donc je crois que là il y
a une carte à jouer une carte à jouer
parce que je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que au niveau des commerces au niveau de
l'hôtellerie au niveau des industries
vient développement de la digitalisation
de ces entreprises là c'est très
important si on veut s'en sortir il faut
passer par là alors je vous donne un
exemple très simple au niveau du
commerce par exemple communiqué il faut
qu'on communique c'est très important
là là là je suis sûr que que le
président de la commission entreprises
de la chambre de commerce française a
mis en valeur le joindre communiqué
c'est très important
il faut absolument maintenant c'est les
réseaux sociaux il faut savoir que le
plus que jamais l'abandon dans son
quitus dans ceux des conditions profiter
je veux vraiment de ceux de ce
dispositif des aides aux entreprises
pour la digitalisation je crois que
c'est primordial pour nos startups aussi
bien pour la formation
c'est important aussi alors dans le
cadre de la formation justement vous
donner un coup de pouce pour aux
entreprises vous dites aux entreprises
donné à donner un coup de jeune en
quelque sorte si vous avez justement
besoin de relancer votre entreprise
après un coup dur alors bas cette crise
de sanitaires c'est un coup dur c'est un
peu dur et donc vous vous préconisez de
faire appel aux apprentis notamment du
cfa tertiaire de la cc de la cci la
chambre de communes on évite donc nous
avons un département apprentiss
apprentissage les entreprises
effectivement à se rapprocher du pôle
consulaire de formation où on met en
relation les entreprises et les jeunes
qui sont là et qui souhaitent intégrer
des entreprises mais c'est important
pour la relance ça aussi c'est très
important
et au niveau de ce pôle consulaires on a
effectivement cette cet outil de
digitalisation mise à disposition de ces
jeunes
donc c'est tout bénef pour les
entreprises on va conclure carole
foulard première vice présidente de la
cci et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie alors ça bruisse ça bruisse
la rumeur enfle on entend dire que le
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie philippe jacot aurait des
velléités de de prendre part aux
élections territoriales alors peut-être
à la tête d'une liste ou en figurant sur
une liste
donc est ce que vous vous apprêtez à
faire un intérim l'a peut-être qu'il va
devoir prendre congé de son mandat là
pour cette campagne électorale vous êtes
dans les confidences
vous savez écouter je ne suis pas dans
les confidences pas encore en tous les
cas
quoi qu'il en soit je trouve que ce
serait peut-être une bonne chose qu' un
socio professionnelles pour peut-être
plus s'intéresser aux problématiques des
entreprises
donc vous dites pourquoi pas je dis
pourquoi pas et vous quelle soit disant
penser à moi je peux pas le dire là où
microsoft offre je suis là pour poser
des questions mais voilà pas pour donner
mon avis personnel merci carole foulard
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
bonne journée et bon courage à tous les
mandants de de la ccm les commerçants et
donc les industriels de de chez nous